welcome back to Piers organizers or
Carrie Lake spent 22 years as a news
anchor in Arizona she's now gone to the
dark side of politics and she's a rising
star in the Republican party I'm gonna
be one it's more controversial figures
lake has been repeatedly talented as a
potential running mate for Donald Trump
but claims she emphatically denies so it
may be true but she has hinted at a run
for the Senate well this weekend she
happened to be in London to witness
history with the coronation of King
Charles and to my delight you've agreed
to come in to my Lair and meet me face
to face so Caroline lovely to meet you
it's so good to be here it's wonderful
to be in London
um we were here for a quite a bit of
history with the coronation and what did
you make of it I thought it was amazing
you know I'm I'm all for countries
making sure that they maintain their
culture and that is such a huge part of
British culture it was wonderful it was
so you know the people of London are
tough that rain coming from the desert
of Arizona I was kind of like do we want
to stand in the rain any longer and then
I decided you know what for history it's
worth it that was like a summer's day
for us
but it was that it was amazing how do
you feel about a monarchy because I
think a lot of Americans it's
interesting obviously you drove us out
he drove King George III out um and
that's how you gained independence as a
country obviously I think that was a
terrible strategic era by the Americas
um but you did what do you feel about
the idea of a monarch it's a whole
debate raging in this country some
people believe it's kind of had his time
well I think I think the culture of
England is amazing and I'm all for 190
different countries in the world
maintaining their culture and it's a
really beautiful part of the culture of
England it's not something we're for
obviously you know 200 and roughly 40
plus years ago we threw off the shackles
of the monarchy in a in a revolution and
uh maintained and and secured our
freedom so it's not for us but I love
the culture I love going to other
countries and experiencing their culture
and it's truly remarkable what you have
here in England and you know this hasn't
happened for what 70 years yeah so I
mean that's the experience you weren't
alive I don't believe thank you
and the last coronation happened 12
years before I was born yes it's been
pretty extraordinary to have gone
through my entire life with one Monarch
yes and I think it's really amazing that
you know it all goes back to God I mean
there's just a really a vein of of God
and Christianity that kind of runs
through this as well and I thought it
was beautiful I think the Pomp and
Circumstance was beautiful again it's
not for us we we're not part of them
didn't give you a little itchy feet to
get the Royals back you did not back in
charge but I did find it wonderful I
found the people have been incredibly
polite and charming and I'm enjoying my
stay in London my sister actually lives
here so it was wonderful to visit with
her a bit as well now I want to talk to
you we've just talked about a rather to
what many Americans are going to
anachronistic part of our culture so let
me talk about what we in Britain would
see as an anachronistic part of your
culture and that's guns now I've I'm not
going to start lecturing you about guts
it's your country your laws your culture
I get all that but there's another mass
shooting this week and it comes off the
back of endless mass shootings more this
year already than any other recorded
year nearly 200 I think now
and this the sort of scale and volume of
these mass shootings seems to be getting
worse and worse what is the answer I
mean what what do you think can be done
because a million new guns are sold
every month
so the volume of guns in circulation
exponentially increases the power of
them seems to be getting uh bigger young
people seem to be suffering in
particular a lot of mental health issues
and it's turning into this awful
Groundhog Day cocktail of people
apparently going mad and committing
heinous mass shootings what do you think
the answer is okay here we are again
right right and and I think I know
you're a father and I'm a mother and
it's it's painful to see anybody any
loss of life especially you know you
never expect your children to die before
you do and in some of these shootings
we've had children dying and adults
dying and we just had a car run down a
bunch of people recently as well we're
not Banning cars or attempting to ban
cars the old regulating cars
regulating them from driving through
crowd well no but it's a very
interesting piece by Nick Kristoff in
the New York Times a few years ago
comparing what happened actually with
car regulation and comparing it to gun
regulation that cars used to kill a lot
of people in America going back a
hundred years when they first came along
and they brought in a series of
regulations from wearing seat belts to
having to have insurance to having to be
registered
someone driving a car in no basically to
a point my point was that his point was
in this very interesting column was that
there were series of regulations were
brought in and the combined effect was
that the mortality rate from car deaths
recruit we're talking about several
things I remember hang on but you raise
cars they decreased by 95 and it was a
very interesting piece which is why
don't you just regulate guns like you
did cars there are millions tens of
millions of of gun owners in America who
wouldn't dream of doing a mass shooting
they're legal their their own their guns
legally and we have a second amendment
it's it's a god-given right it's in our
constitution do you think
the founding fathers have been
comfortable
watching this absolutely never-ending
series of mass shootings would they have
thought that was what they meant by the
Second Amendment would they have looked
to perhaps to tailor it to Modern
founding fathers would have never been
okay with what they're seeing right now
which is tyranny on our Land once again
and the second amendment was put in
place we already pushed back the tyrants
once and we didn't give up we clung to
our our guns who's the Tyranny The
Tyranny was from the monarchy and now
we're seeing an overreaching government
we're seeing a line media lying to us
taking our livelihoods away with covid
restrictions and imposing all of that on
our children and on our families and on
our education and we don't want to have
to throw back the tyrants again but they
put that in place to pres prevent us
from having to do that to protect us I
will tell you this as a mother I'm
horrified to see anybody hurt but I
don't know you haven't been on the
streets of America lately the crime is
out of control I've seen it it's not
safe to walk down these Democrat
controlled cities the murderer
I am a much better mother that I have
firearms and can protect my family and I
will protect my family you call 9-1-1
right now you can't get someone to show
up at your house Pierce and there's
crime and violence happening on our
streets and we need to protect our own
families okay but here's my question for
you I don't dispute anything you've just
said
what I would say is this something has
to be done we can agree on this right a
Fox News poll revealed that 87 of
Americans back stricter background
checks 81 agree the legal age to buy a
gun to be raised to 21. 80 agreed that
anyone who buys a gun should go for a
mental health assessment 80 percent want
police to take guns from people
considered a danger to themselves 77
what a 30-day waiting up period for all
gun purchases okay that doesn't surprise
me because this is a would you support
this Fox News is a globalist network
pushing a globalist agenda and the
globalists want to make sure Fox News is
watched by a lot of gun owners Fox News
is a globalist network run by globalists
who want to bring down our Constitution
and take away our sector everybody who
took part in that independent poll is a
globalists tax news is a globalist
network let's let's just face it we all
know the truth here I don't think
it's the biggest conservative Network in
the country most of it fired Tucker Carl
but most of it's most of its viewers I
suspect would have a pro-gun view and
you're 80 of them want all these new
measures brought it would you not agree
with any of them if you pass any of
those and make those laws they're
unconstitutional we have a constitution
you wouldn't bring in anything the
Constitution is not going anywhere I
understand that would you not bring in
any new regulations no I'm not going to
change the Second Amendment our
constitutional rights just like I don't
change the First Amendment you don't
even want background checks I don't want
to change our constitution not even
background checks Pierce
our second amendment allows me to
protect my family it allows me to
protect my children and right now we're
living in a very dangerous place I'm
sure the Streets of London aren't safe
either but the streets of America you go
to Portland you go to San Francisco LA
Phoenix and you wouldn't dare walk down
the street at night even in the middle
of broad daylight and feel safe you're
not safe okay look at this you see what
these are
do you know where they are what is it
Kinder surprise chocolate egg
so the thing about the surprise is there
are little toys inside the chocolate
eggs I've got two of them here these are
legal here that's why I'm allowed to use
them
um and they were very popular in America
and then they got banned they're illegal
in America because the CDC decided that
the toys inside because they were buried
inside the chocolate or a choking hazard
guess what the CDC also is the one who
forced masks on our children's faces the
CDC Force masks children's faces for two
years
what the CDC says they do not control
let me know a Second Amendment do you
think they should be banned
probably not I think we're overarching
with our with ourselves a British prime
minister told me this is a true story is
this what we're going to talk about
we're all the way here in London we want
to talk about little chocolate eggs
really actually the relevances there's a
British prime minister told me recently
that he was stopped to LAX Airport
and he had his Kinder surprise chocolate
things confiscated because they were a
danger to children and yet the number
one killer of children now in America is
guns and yet America will not regulate
guns number one they regulate chocolate
eggs the number one I simply asked why
the number one killer of young people
and I call young people 20 and younger
is fentanyl and it's pouring across our
Southern border and no one seems to give
it that's not true the number one killer
is guns no number one killer is fentanyl
of our young number one killer children
but we can disagree on that well it's a
fact it's not okay well I'm I'm worried
as a mother about the fentanyl killing
she knows they find that extraordinary I
think it's ridiculous akin to surprise
chocolate egg is banned in America
because it may choke how out of touch
these these government agencies like the
CDC and the ATF are they're completely
out of touch they're wasting their time
on that meanwhile they're imposing mask
guidelines and and forcing our beautiful
children to have masks on their face
that's how Auto touch the CDC is we need
to take away the cdc's power they're out
of touch they're completely out of time
you want to regulate the CDC I want to
take away their power they are an agency
they have no power over us and they're
trying to impose power but just finally
on guns you wouldn't want to implement
any of these things which 80 percent of
what I wanted to do is protect our
Second Amendment at all costs and you
wouldn't bring in any new regulations at
all I don't see new regulations coming
in now they're unconstitutional Pierce
even if somebody in Congress wanted to
where does it say in the Constitution we
can't bring in new regulations that
shall not be infringed our Second
Amendment shall not be that means he
can't ever change it at all listen he's
already an amendment you can try if you
want but good luck because it's the
second amendment it's enshrined in our
constitution it's a god-given right and
we're not going to give it up how do you
stop the mass shootings if you never do
anything this is how you stop them we
start to address mental illness we're
not addressing that our children are
under a lot of stress right now the
world is a dangerous place our children
are feeling distressed they're going to
school they're being psychologically
abused in school with indoctrination
we're also seeing all kinds of violence
on the streets that our children are
feeling that as well covid was difficult
for our children our young people are
suffering and instead of going after And
discussing mental illness and trying to
find some answers to that we put push
big Pharma on them and we over we have
the same no no we give them two meds
here's my answer talk about big Pharma
just like you can't talk about them
industrial complex
as they control the media you can
control me you cannot talk about big
Pharma famously nobody controls me you
cannot no no you can't talk about big
Pharma right now you can't talk about
how dangerous the vaccines are you can't
talk about I don't think the vaccines
were dangerous really no you're not
seeing some of the consequences no I
think the vaccines actually were in
remarkably safe save millions of lives
wow actually they had the same amount of
side effects I understand you are
networking millions of dollars in
advertisements nobody's told me to say
this I disagree with Fox about a number
of things I worked in I worked in media
for 30 years I get you have to protect
the sponsor and the sponsors who am I
protecting the sponsor's big fight I
happen to believe the vaccines were
comparatively safe to other vaccines I
think like all vaccines they have side
effects but a lot of the stuff talked
about the side of things and the
supposed millions of people okay dying
so it's complete nonsense okay I believe
well we can disagree okay let's talk
about something we could probably agree
on is Joe Biden too old to be running
for president I don't think age is a
factor just as I don't think you're all
too old to be a news anchor thank you I
wasn't aware this was a talk but what it
is more is a mental state and a
cognitive ability and I think that we
knew going into this that cognitively he
wasn't prepared and more horrifying than
his cognitive ability
is his ethics he's unethical he's taken
payouts from the CCP he's taken money
from Ukraine he's in my opinion acted in
a criminal manner against the people of
America he's supposed to be protecting
our citizens he's supposed to be
representing America and he's shown more
Allegiance toward the CCP and Ukraine
has nothing to do with his age
I my father was a very sound mind right
up until his death you could not say he
had one slip in cognitive ability but
Joe Biden cognitively is not prepared
for what he has coming at him and more
importantly I think he's he's got blood
on his hands with the way he's handled
so who should take him on the borders
from the Republicans carry who should
take him on who's got the best chance of
beating him of course you know the
answer to that music is Donald Trump
Donald J Trump but I would argue
genuinely and I've known Trump a long
time as you know I would argue he might
be the only way the Democrats win the
next one sweet baloney it's hogwashing
like they did last time it's hard I've
beaten him once it's hogwash really
nobody in America believes that election
was fair Joe Biden didn't win you're not
in America let me remind you I do
believe that but not never mind me so do
a lot of senior Republicans okay
uh you know 81 million votes is
impossible Joe Biden didn't Garner 81
million it was a free and fair election
only one well you can say that a million
times it doesn't make it true but it's
like your election in Arizona same thing
do you really want to argue about the
elections I'm happy to only that you and
Trump both refuse to accept the result
of democratic elections and I say to you
in all sincerity I think it's a it's a
it's a vote losing premise that's fine
to keep saying I didn't lose when you
did you're better off going I lost that
time next time I'm going to win I
totally understand that I understand
what you're saying and I would just ask
this when you voted when was the last
time you voted here yes uh in the last
election okay so you voted if you'd
shown up and they said you're going to
wait five hours and 61 of the polling
locations had function non-functioning
equipment you waited five hours you
showed up to vote and the tabulator
refused your ballot and they said you
know what go down the road would you be
okay with that you have to prove them
you haven't it's been independently
established you haven't proven it was
allegations I wish you were there you
say you were robbed Trump says look
Trump in the face and I've liked Donald
personally a long time but I said to him
I don't know why you keep saying you won
the 2020. nobody wants to go back look
forward offer America a positive future
give them a reason to vote for you next
time hanging on about 2020. the reason
you're a rising look you're great on TV
you're very personable you're very
confident you had a little setback when
you lost why don't you just say you know
what all the greats lose all the great
Sports people talk about the power of
losing and then winning again and coming
back why not take that position rather
than saying you know what I'm just not
going to accept it I'll take my toys and
run off home and you're not going to
play with them anymore I'm sorry that's
how you see it well you know what I mean
I'm sorry you see it that way the way
that I see it and what I'm fighting for
are the people of Arizona and their vote
was taken from them we we have corrupted
to prove it Carrie may I speak you may
we have corrupt election officials we
have corrupt elections they printed the
wrong image on the ballot on Election
Day why is it not been established
independently and Maricopa County hasn't
has not rebutted that they haven't
they have not denied that and so I
encourage you to take a look at her do
you want to be senator in Arizona I'd
love you to go to my Rumble page and
take a look at our court case and see
how it played out I didn't watch the
whole thing uh okay let me ask you
you've scratched a little bit of surface
to act like you're aware of what's
happening but you're oh I just said the
light Donald Trump you've got to produce
the hard evidence or you've got to
explain what we've got you were robbed
of here that's what we've got to do is
fight for fair elections so that every
voter I don't care if they're the most
America has some of the fairest I don't
care in the world that's that's
completely you do your system is
incredible vote for 28 days in Arizona
we count for 14 days that's right for
frost you want to be Senator I want to
see elections answer my question
I'm not sure what my future holds to be
honest I'm working right now on our
election case that's the center of my
would you like to be senator of Arizona
and and if for some reason we don't get
a fair outcome in our election I will
run for Senate most likely you will most
likely so you declaring now no I'm
saying most likely if we don't have a
fair outcome in our election case that I
may consider running for Senate if
Donald Trump says she wants you to be
his running mate what do you say we've
had this conversation come on I said if
the royal family invites you in and they
want you to come in I said yes you said
yes good for you I don't think president
Trump needs a vice president he's that
powerful he's going to have to Peter if
he runs he's that powerful as a leader
he doesn't really need one but I do hope
he picks somebody who the media fears
more than they fear him is that you and
you know why I think he should do that
because then they'll stop trying to take
him down he's the one man fighting for
us in America you may not see it here
across the pond as they say he's the one
man who's been fighting for us and they
have been gunning for him since day one
the media has been lying about him since
day one with bogus phony
BS stories and now they're doing a bunch
of bogus phony cases against him and
that American people are on to it they
recognize he's the one man that's
standing in that Gap to protect the
people of America I don't think they're
bogus you know what I thought I thought
the Stormy Daniels indictment was a
stupid thing to go after him about I
think an ex-president paying hush money
to a porn star to cover up an affair
it's not a serious enough thing for him
to be indicted over however I do think
some of the other legal issues is in are
really serious potentially I think I
think what it does is it allows you to
say what you just said keep this in the
media we'll keep it in the media we can
talk about porn I don't have a dog in
the race we can talk about uh Aging Care
whatever we can talk about all this
stuff and it keeps it out there as a
reminder to people little little brain
worms going into people's heads to try
to turn them against Trump they're not
going to be turned against Trump because
the people of America know he's fighting
for us the people who hate Trump
the globalist he's got he's got the
right kind of sounds like you're making
a little campaign she's got that to the
president to be his running mate he's
got the right kind of enemies and I'm
fighting for him you know why I'm
fighting for him you know I'm out here
speaking for him has nothing to do with
me I want nothing I want nothing in
return if you practice your first five
president speech I want nothing in
return for me speaking up for him other
than I want my country back I want my
children to live in an America where we
have our freedoms and our liberties
intact and we're this close to losing
that and it scares the hell out of me as
a mother I'm just a mom I'm truly a
citizen who decided to step forward and
run for office and I've been attacked by
the media I sit down I get hostile
interviews and I take everything
no this is actually a little more polite
you've got the British polite thank you
which is great
um but I don't care what people call me
I care about my country and we're on the
verge of losing it and I would hope that
here in Britain if you guys are facing
the same fate that you would be standing
up for your country absolutely
absolutely I love people to stand up for
their country Carrie it's great to meet
you Michael great wise thank you for
coming in it's wonderful here I'll be
watching what happens with you with
great interest thank you good to see you
here's a Kinder egg
I can't you can't have them back home
because they might it might be harmful
to children
good to see